el tercero mandato de Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva empezó de manera muy turbulenta
con un ataque a las instituciones del
país por Los partidarios de rayer
bolsonaro desde entonces el gobierno de
nula hizo todo lo que puede para dejar
en el olvido este episodio repudiado por
la mayoría pero revelador de la profunda
polarización que perdura en el país Lula
este curso de inmediato manos a la obra
restableció programas sociales como el
emblemático bolsa familia que fue
ampliado revocó varias leyes que
facilitaban el porte de armas en enero
ordenó una acción firme de las fuerzas
armadas contra la minería ilegal en las
tierras Y llanomani acabando Juan con
cuatro años de omisión del gobierno de
Jair bolsonaro Lula tuvo bastante éxito
en su intento de reposicionar a la
política externa de Brasil y normalizar
relaciones con ciertos países visitó a
los presidentes de Argentina de Estados
Unidos y viajará en las próximas horas a
China mayor socio comercial de Brasil a
pesar de estos logros según una encuesta
29% de brasileños reprueban a Lula un
nivel casi igual al que le enfrentaba su
antecesor después de 100 días de mandato